it's about the question what is reality
but it's also about the meta questions
um so digging into the potential answers
to the question itself but also to
question that question
so
um
physics is
insanely successful almost unbelievably
successful in its predictive power about
nature but there's there's a sense and I
think a growing sense that physics has
stalled in I think what some once
thought was this final Sprint to a
theory of everything you know to to
neatly tie up reality in a bow have this
final equation that described everything
uh and so uh so now many physicists are
asking how do we approach the question
differently
um and not just physicists a lot of the
thinking is Reaching Across into other
disciplines
um drawing on other disciplines okay can
you give an example of that because you
said you would like to investigate
fundamental reality from not just a
physics perspective but a science
perspective in general what would that
look like if not physics
great question so so I guess um
there's a lot many ways to uh answer
that but
let's just use one so uh
quantum mechanics is
weird beyond comprehension in a very
literal sense we still don't get it
um but it's clear that there is a
an uncanny and fundamental Link Between
The Observer and the nature of the
observed the so-called measurement
problem
and this is a
an unresolved uh
um conundrum that was sort of swept
under the rug you know back in the 1920s
when we realized that there was
some kind of
in between
observations there there is there's a
level of indeterminacy to Nature in
which nature
appears to occupy multiple States at
once or no State and it's only defined
on observation and all of this all this
beautiful weird stuff and
um there there was a lot of debate about
you know basically swing between a type
of idealism and a type of realism
um questioning the reality of reality
um and how fundamental The Observer is
but this was pushed aside uh because
quantum mechanics was
incredibly successful at predicting the
behavior of the universe and so you know
the old added shut up and calculate uh
really drove the the philosophy of how
quantum mechanics evolved um
in that we just used it we we used it to
make amazing predictions I think it's
reasonable to say we used quantum
mechanics to build our modern world you
know
translated mindset is what it is yeah
yeah it is so it so
for quite some time it was
considered career suicide for an
academic to ask questions like but what
does quantum mechanics actually mean
um what is happening between
measurements for example sort of the the
what we call the interpretation of
quantum mechanics so the equations work
you know the Schrodinger equation or the
equations of quantum field Theory they
work incredibly well but asking the
question what do these equations mean
what is the
physical story that they
are the world you just watched a clip
from the theories of everything channel
for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy